let me just start off by saying that
pachinko is one of the best shows of
2022. if you haven't seen it do yourself
a favor steal your friend's apple plus
and give it a shot bring lots of tissues
because if you're a big baby like me
you'll be crying every episode but one
of the things that makes this show
unique is the way in which it tells the
story that spans over four generations
one minute you're in 1989 japan and the
next in 1915 korea to better encapsulate
this epic tale i thought it would be fun
to see how the story plays out
chronologically keep in mind this will
only be covering the television show and
i have not read the book so any theories
i might have are my own and feel free to
laugh at me for getting them wrong and
of course please forgive my terrible
korean japanese pronunciation the show
starts in 1915 on a character named yang
jin we're in japanese occupied korea
five years after japan has taken control
of the country in its efforts to grow
its empire jung-jin believes her blood
to be cursed her previous three children
died before reaching the age of one but
she's undergoing a ritual that should
relieve her of this later that year
she'll give birth to pachinko's main
protagonist sunjib bake the next part of
the timeline we actually don't have an
exact year but by doing some backward
math we can guess this is roughly 1921
when sunja is about 7 or 8 years old
through her eyes we see how the korean
people are treated under japanese rule
it's around this time that her father
dies and she is forced to scrape by and
help her mother tend to the boarding
house two years later across the sea in
yokohama japan we meet koh han soo a
young math tutor with dreams of
traveling to america he and his father
live a simple life but when his dad owes
money to ryo ichi a member of the yakuza
hansu does whatever he can to help pay
off his father's debt but his father
dies in the great kanto earthquake
before this debt can be paid leaving
hanso with its burden forcing him to
work for raioichi to pay it off not much
is known about hansu and what he did in
this time between working for the yakuza
and ending up in korea as the district
fish broker where sanja lives but we do
know he has a reputation as being some
sort of criminal or gangster in this
time he's also forced to marry a woman
he does not love this takes us to
roughly 1930 where hansu ends up in
yeongdo korea and meets an older sunja
there they have a romantic affair which
ends up in sunja pregnant around 1931.
it's a bit unclear how long this affair
lasted but the montage in episode 3
suggests this wasn't a one-time thing in
normal circumstances the two would marry
but hansu cannot having already married
a woman back home for business reasons
so hansu promises sunja a life where she
the child and her mother will want for
nothing however no marriage sunja will
reject this offer telling solomon
decades later that she couldn't live
with her life being split in half one
hidden and one that she could talk about
this is also where we get the arrival of
isaac who crosses paths with sunja while
recovering from tuberculosis knowing
that finding a wife that would take on a
sick man like himself would be difficult
he proposes that he and sanja mary
almost no man would take on a woman with
a child out of wedlock so this becomes a
marriage of convenience that he hopes
could blossom into love it is later in
1931 that they moved to osaka japan
leaving behan sunja's mother and giving
birth to hansu's son noah six years
later also in osaka sunja gives birth to
her second child mozasu who is her and
isaac's only biological child and half
brother to noah and a year after that
around the time of mozasso's first
birthday isaac is taken into custody by
the japanese police under suspicion that
he's a communist it's also here that
noah unknowingly meets his father hansu
who seems to be keeping a watchful eye
over his son at the end of the season
sunja tells noah that she's going to get
isaac back and i wonder if this means
she'll have to go back to hansu for this
help the period between 1938 and 1975 is
the biggest chunk of time that the
series does not explore however with the
show being renewed for season 2 they'll
undoubtedly explore these decades there
are a lot of unanswered questions here
like where is muzasu what happened to
isaac and what became of hansu i
wouldn't be surprised if mamuriyoshi's
grandfather the one who is mentioned as
being a criminal gangster comes into
play during this time period especially
considering solomon and memorial get
into business with each other at the end
of the season our next significant time
period is 1975 where a 14 year old
solomon has fallen in love with his
father's girlfriend's daughter hannah he
ends up stealing from a local
convenience store where he gets caught
and his father ships him off to america
1975 to 1989 is the second biggest gap
in the pachinko story we know that
solomon spent his time attending yale
and working his way up in business his
father also started growing his own
pachinko parlor but it's 1989 where much
of our story comes to a head solomon
returns to japan believing he can
convince a local korean woman to sell
her land to the company he works for
what ensues is an internal dilemma
between solomon's allegiance to his
company and to his family and heritage
he ends up bungling the deal which gets
him fired and later will meet a
notorious businessman by the name of
mamuro yoshi solomon's character arc is
very interesting it goes from
indifference towards his heritage to
sticking up for his heritage to actively
defending it by vowing to destroy the
very people he used to work for it's his
way of getting back at the people who
subjugated his family and people season
two will likely continue this timeline
with solomon and mamuru's partnership
which i think will delve into the
criminal underworld linking historically
with whatever hansu was up to back in
the first half of the century whatever
happens i thoroughly enjoyed pachinko
and i'm so excited that apple decided to
give it a season 2. if you liked this
video make sure to like and comment
every little bit helps thanks for
watching for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt and until next time
remember chateau badaweizer day
competition